bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france alors
on va commencer par vous pour l'instant
puisque notre deuxième but rennais n'est
pas là mais dit bourny sa merci d'être
avec nous lors de son allocution lors
cette invitation mais je vous en prie
lors de son allocution au français
avant-hier emmanuel macron a parlé d'un
contexte de choc de grandes puissances
et curieusement il a inclus les états
unis avec la chine et la russie écoutez
il faut réaffirmer notre indépendance
gaullienne je prône une nouvelle amitié
avec la russie je refuse le suivisme
atlantisme nos ennemis ce sont les
islamistes pas les russes l'intervention
russe en syrie a été déterminante face à
l'état islamique c'est une erreur du
président français de ne pas avoir
répondu à la proposition des russes pour
mettre au point le vaccin ensemble
puisqu'ils étaient avancées et que nous
savons le faire les russes sont des
partenaires fiables alors que les états
unis ne le sont pas
alors on s'était emmanuel macron sur le
choc des puissances continentales qui se
déploie sous nos yeux que seule une
entente européenne solidaire et
volontaire peut apporter à chacun de nos
pays européens c'est dans ce contexte du
choc des puissances américaines
chinoises et russes
contexte de déstabilisation des grandes
puissances a dit emmanuel macron comment
est-ce que vous analysez cette phrase du
chef de l'état est il devenu un peu
moins atlantiste emmanuel macron
je pense que par la force des choses il
ne peut pas l'être étant donné que l'une
dernier point qui va être très important
c'est finalement est ce que la question
internationale va être un sujet pour la
prochaine élection présidentielle moi je
pense que ça va l'être dans la mesure où
on a bien vu que les questions
internationales sont en train de prendre
beaucoup d'importance on a vu avec la
avec le contrat des sous marins
australiens on a vu ensuite avec les le
problème de la pêche entre les français
les anglais plus généralement de l'union
européenne et des conséquences du
breakbeat
et on pourrait citer d'autres problèmes
là vous parlais tout à l'heure de de
cabella à risques est venue donc on à
paris pour discuter de la paix notamment
la libye il ya des partenaires notamment
de la france en afrique et qui ont de
grandes frontière avec la libye et
l'algérie qui ont décidé de pas venir
donc on aimerait que du fait aussi de
l'arrogance du de la politique étrangère
du président la république
malheureusement il n'a pas d'autre choix
que d'essayer de multiplier les
interlocuteurs parce qu'il s'est bien
rendu compte que le président qui
voulait parler à tout le monde ne parle
finalement plus à personne effectivement
comme ça c'est le premier allez-y pardon
je vous ai coupé oui aucun problème et
donc le sujet qui est très important je
pense pour pour pour cette campagne ça
va être surtout proposer une troisième
voie on voit bien que le prêt de la
république arrive dans une situation où
il n'a plus beaucoup la main il veut
bien sûr parler aux états unis il n'a
pas le choix il veut essayer de parler
aux chinois les chinois ne l'écoutent
pas je vous rappelle quand même qu'à
l'époque de trump il a essayé d'avoir
une relation personnelle qui n'a
débouché sur rien il a essayé aussi de
draguer
vladimir poutine en invitant d'abord à
versailles et ensuite à brégançon et sad
and alpha n'a débouché sur rien donc il
peut toujours tenter d'essayer de
discuter et moi je pense qu'il faut
discuter avec tout le monde je pense
qu'il faut pas être nostalgique en
politique internationale je pense qu'il
faut plutôt être dynamique il ya une
tectonique des plaques qui est
importante la chine fait face à des
défis importants économique elle va elle
fait face aussi à des défis
démographiques
le président chez jean king va vers sans
doute un troisième mandat en 2023 c'est
un pays qui a une fenêtre de tir en cas
d'opportunité et aux politiques qui va
devoir saisir assez rapidement je lui la
france il veut parler à tout le monde et
même là qu on vous l'avait bien dit mais
un ace qu'il ait entendu est ce qu'il
est audible surtout un an je pense qu'il
ne l'est plus je pense qu'il ne l'est
plus et c'est tout le problème c'est
tout le problème et c'est aussi pour ça
et je souhaite vraiment que les choses
soient claires emmanuel macron va
prendre la présidence de l'union
européenne à partir de janvier en jouant
sur le calendrier du brésil parce que si
le président n'avait pas eu lieu la
france n'aurait pas été à la présidence
en plein milieu d'une d'une campagne
présidentielle du coup ça ne va pas
servir ni les intérêts de la france au
sein de l'union européenne vise les
intérêts l'union européenne parce que ce
qu'on voit aussi avec ce qui se passe
aux frontières de l'europe en pologne
c'est que l'europe a besoin aussi de
parler de manière plus jeune de deux
manières plus unie de parler de manière
plus forte est aussi de proposer un
projet qui a vécu au quel les européens
vont adhérer c'est à dire qu'à un moment
donné l'euro nous a sauvés c'est vrai
pendant cette crise mais on peut pas
continuellement parler de taux d'intérêt
en europe il faut tendre de la
protection des européens et les
représentants européens pardon j'ai fini
juste là dessus elle passe par un bail
en actes elle passe par le développement
d'une industrie donc par une réforme du
droit de la concurrence et tout ça ce
n'est pas mises sur la table ont nagé à
michel qui est avec nous par téléphone
malheureusement on a un problème de
connexion ce matin jérémy michel avocat
au barreau des hauts-de-seine et les
membres des amis et d'eric zemmour
bonjour bienvenue à vous je ne sais pas
si vous avez entendu le débat en cours
avec mehdi bourny ça on parlait de la
vision du monde emmanuel macron et le
fait peut-être qu'ils se détachent un
peu des états unis avec ce qu'il a dit
lors de son allocution mardi quand il a
placé les états unis dans le choc des
grandes puissances entre la chine les
etats-unis et la russie est ce qu
emmanuel macron devient moins atlantiste
et quelle ville on vous fait de son
action à l'international
bonjour j'ai écouté déjà merci beaucoup
de me recevoir
alors c'est c'est très simple avec
emmanuel macron comme d'habitude tout
est dans le discours est absolument rien
dans les actes la politique étrangère du
président était un désastre absolu que
ce soit en termes d'indépendance
contrairement à ce qu'il avait annoncé
au moment de sa campagne en parlant de
gaulle au mitterrandisme ou ou en
matière de deux puissances on peut
penser si on doit faire le bilan comme
vous me l'avez demandé on peut penser à
la ferraille ce tome quand il était
ministre encore ministre de l'économie
qui nous avait vus perdre une de nos
pépites industriel est une technologie
très importante
pour les sous marins nucléaires les
turbines arabe l on a plus récemment en
effet ce fiasco
qu'ils aient eu lieu avec ce contrat
pour les sous marins australiens là
encore on a eu des mots on a eu des
rodomontades de la part du président
et puis quelques jours après il s'est
réconcilié en grande pompe avec joe
biden qui s'est un peu moqué de lui et
par la même occasion un peu moqué de la
france en indiquant qu'il n'était pas au
courant que la france n'était pas au
courant que le contrat n'allait pas donc
sur le fond si vous voulez emmanuel
macron et encore comme le dirait xénon à
son stage de l'ena donc c'est pas mal
puisqu'il reprend les analyses d'eric
zemmour et d'autre part ailleurs sur le
siècle qui s'ouvre et qui sera en effet
on n'est plus dans l'affrontement bloc
contre bloc contre l'urss ou ou la
russie mais on est dans un siècle où en
effet les états unis et la chine vont
entrer dans une période de tensions
voire de tension maximale les etats unis
sont en train de réorganiser tout leur
réseau d'alliances dans le pacifique
autour de cette question et nous de
notre côté si vous voulez la france qui
est qui n'est plus la grande puissance
qui n'a pu être à une époque mais qui
reste une grande puissance avec
énormément d'atouts avec le deuxième
espace maritime avec le le feu nucléaire
avec sa place au conseil de sécurité
deux des nations unies
la france a son rôle à jouer en tant que
puissance d' équilibre pour être capable
justement de dialoguer avec avec tout le
monde et malheureusement emmanuel macron
lui se fâche avec tout le monde il se
fâche avec les etats-unis se fâche avec
la pologne il se fâche avec la
biélorussie se fâche avec l'algérie se
fâche avec tout le monde donc on a un
président est véritablement un amateur
en matière de politique étrangère il
faudrait dans ce domaine réinstaurer du
sérieux une réaction kamala harris état
est à paris
aujourd'hui pour inaugurer avec emmanuel
macron justement le congrès de paris
pour la paix ça a été instaurée par
emmanuel macron en 2018 c'est plutôt un
concert pour le davos du numérique mehdi
bourny ça ça sert à quoi ce congrès de
paris pour vous
écoutez moi je pense à rien le problème
c'est que avec emmanuel macron on a
essayé d'être partout nous l'apprennent
c'est quand on n'est pas retournée nul
par mois il se trouve que je suis
français de l'étranger et à chaque fois
que emmanuel macron fait une erreur en
matière de politique internationale nous
sommes les premiers à le payer cash
parce que les il ya eu un moment donné
aussi un sentiment anti français parce
que cette arrogance de vouloir tous les
autres partout la france a là des
centres d'intérêt et de l' influence de
certaines parties du monde adoré si
recentrer moyen-orient en afrique on a
vu qu'en afrique elle avait énormément
de mal énormément de mal à se
repositionner et au moyen-orient elle a
pris beaucoup elle a perdu beaucoup
prises et donc faire venir des gens pour
discuter de paix alors que finalement on
libye on a eu un moment un double jeu
que finalement on est on est incapable
de réunir toutes les parties prenantes
sur un conflit comme celui là que
finalement les etats-unis qui viennent
donner des leçons ont quand même aussi
fait une espèce d'ingérence régionales
en se mêlant notamment d'un conflit
régional entre le maroc et l'algérie qui
va sans doute à un moment donné nous
retomber dessus parce qu'on est les plus
proches partenaires du maroc et de
l'algérie en toute franchise je pense
que c'est beaucoup de blabla et
finalement très peu d'action on va
parler de l'europe à présent et du
premier déplacement de marine le pen
c'est son premier déplacement pendant sa
campagne ça a été la hongrie pour marine
le pen tout comme eric zemmour qui lui
je le précise n'est pas en campagne
officiellement réécouter ce qu'a dit
marine le pen sur l'europe
lui a dérivé en organisation fédérale et
en pouvoir centralisé bruxellois els
sans visage de plus en plus comme un
état unitaire centralisé un empire
pouvoir centralisé enivré de sa propre
existence de sa puissance et de son
omnipotence avec une volonté
d'asservissement et non une volonté de
coopération jérémy michel quelle est la
position d'eric zemmour sur l'europe
précisément est-ce que c'est semblable à
ce que dit marine n
pas tout à fait même si mais même si
marine le pen
est capable parfois des moments de
lucidité en matière de politique
étrangère mais sur l'union européenne et
pas uniquement sur l'europe d'abord eric
zemmour est un européen convaincu d'un
point de vue civilisationnel et culturel
maintenant ce qui concerne l'union
européenne en effet récemment on peut se
demander à quelle osseuse ou la
commission européenne quand on voit par
exemple ce qui se passe en pologne avec
la frontière biélorusse
les les remontrances qui sont faits par
l'union faites par l'union européenne
vis-à-vis du gouvernement polonais qui
essaie de défendre sa frontière et par
là même de défendre les frontières de
l'europe et donc les frontières de la
france puisque avec schengen on circule
librement vous l'aurez compris au sein
de l'union européenne
là il y a il ya questions à poser et on
peut se demander quelle est quelle est
la logique de la commission européenne
ce qui est certain
c'est que et je pense ou l'aurez compris
au sud et d analyse d'eric zemmour les
pays doivent être souverain qu'il
s'agisse de la pologne de la hongrie ou
de la france et en la matière certes
nous avons des partenariats privilégiés
avec nos amis européens mais il faut que
nous soyons capables en tant que pays et
en tant que puissance d'avoir nos
propres intérêts nous n'avons pas tous
la même géographie pas tous la même
culture comme tous le même rapport à
l'histoire et aux relations
internationales
de ce fait il faut que nous ayons nous
soyons capables d'avoir une voix
indépendante est en réalité on ne peut
pas avoir une voix unie
à 27 au sein de l'union européenne
si nous ne sommes pas capables d'être
tous d'accord sur tout c'est très
compliqué à ce nombre là d'être d'accord
sur tout et mehdi bon et ça on connaît
la position des républicains sur sur
l'europe pro européen quel est le
constat que vous faites sur la le mandat
des manuels macron il voulait réformer
continuer la récente des institutions
aujourd'hui il ya un budget a minima
pâte pas de défense européenne est ce
qu'il va pouvoir imprimer sa marque à
partir de janvier vous pensez non moi je
pense qu'il n'arrivera pas à la imprimer
sa marque il a déjà loupé le coche au
moment du breakbeat et à un moment où
l'italie et l'espagne est en situation
politique assez compliqué il n'a pas
réussi à prendre le leadership
il n'a pas comme vous dites vous le dis
vous le rappeler très bien de finalement
le seul crédit qui va essayer de mettre
à son avantage ça va être ce moment
hamiltonien où il a essayé de faire une
espèce de budget commun mais c'est un
personne n'est dupe c'est finalement la
crise ça de la crise sanitaire qui a
forcé le pas et puis c'est l'allemagne
qui a surtout voulu pousser sur ce sujet
la france seule ne l'aurait pas pu et
puis notre crédibilité financière avec
la dette qui explose est entamée et puis
surtout il a agacé beaucoup de nos
partenaires je pense aux néerlandais que
avec qui pourtant pourraient avoir des
points de concordance et c'est ce que
j'ai rappelé au tout début je pense que
les deux sujets enfin le sujet qui est
important c'est aussi et pour que
l'europe soit mieux acceptées qu'elles
reviennent aussi dans sa mission
première c'est de servir en tant
qu'européen ça peut pas être simplement
un endroit où on signe des traités de
libre échange on a un marché unique il
faut déjà qu'on aille au bout de ce
marché unique avec une vraie intégration
fiscale on a dû attendre un coup de
boutoir de joe biden pour relancer le
projet de l'impôt minimum ce qui est
dommage et puis l'autre sujet c'est bien
sûr que l'europe profite aux européens à
travers une commande publique européenne
à travers un wan lan quand la
concurrence qui ne regarde plus comme
marché pertinent l'europe mais le monde
entier parce que nos concurrents qui
sont dans le monde sont en chine sont
japon ils sont aux etats unis ils ne
sont pas en europe en europe on a des
partenaires est justement là où tout le
monde s'extasie sur sur ce que vient de
faire thomas pesquet sp6 n'aurait jamais
pu voir le jour sans de la pression sur
le sang de la sueur la capacité
d'anticiper la commande publique et on
arrivera à ce niveau là si on n'a pas
une europe qui d'abord sert ses
concitoyens ces entreprises jérémy
michel on va parler de la politique
arabe la france a longtemps eu une
politique pro arabe emmanuel macron lui
a voulu se poser en médiateur
international on en a parlé un petit peu
avec vous mais dit pour nice a
notamment en syrie en libye on l'a dit
mais aussi au liban
coquelles constat vous faites de ces
tentatives de médiation
le constat est simple un échec total et
un effacement de
de la puissance de la france et de son
influence dans toutes ces zones
sa tentative de médiation et du banc a
échoué a échoué totalement et on
constate par ailleurs dans tout le
moyen-orient une diminution
de l'affluence de de la france si on
prend le dossier syrien la france ait
été emmanuel macron à était l'héritier
finalement de la position et des erreurs
et des errements de françois hollande là
dessus mais la france était à la
remorque des etats-unis en syrie
incapable de définir elle-même sa sa
ligne 7 sa ligne de politique étrangère
donc là aussi ça a été ça a été un échec
donc globalement si vous voulez la
politique la politique arabe de la
france comme on comme on le disait
autrement est resté est restée lettre
morte tout simplement parce qu'il n'y a
pas de politique du tout eric zemmour
s'est récemment exprimé sur le conflit
au proche-orient en voyez ce qu'il en
pense
je pense que la solution à deux états
est une logorrhée dépasser les
palestiniens ont perdu la bataille ils
n'auront jamais d'état
c'était aussi la position à demi-mot de
donald trump on compare souvent
d'ailleurs eric zemmour a à donald trump
qu'est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette comparaison en matière de
politique étrangère y at-il des
similitudes
encore une fois la france et la france
et les etats-unis sont les états unis
donc comparaison
n'est pas raison eric zemmour au fil de
ses analyses et si demain je l'espère il
était candidat défendra l'intéressent de
la france c'est à dire que la france sa
politique étrangère ne doit être décidé
ni à washington ni et khâgne à moscou
mais à paris voilà donc ça c'est un
premier point maintenant sur ce qui est
du conflit
israélo palestinien
ça fait des décennies en effet qu'on
nous ressasse cette solution à deux
états
la position d'eric zemmour sur cette
question et une position réaliste il est
clair que sur le terrain cette solution
à deux états est de plus en plus battu
en brèche c'est qu'en réalité
il semblerait qu'on ne puisse pas aller
vers cela donc il faut prendre en compte
ce changement de paradigme et essayer de
trouver d'autres solutions pour pour
assurer une paix une paix durable et
puis la sécurité autant des peines bien
que des designers existent eux mans
mehdi bournissac et magnanac on n'a pas
été très actif sur ce dossier
israélo-palestinien est ce que vous le
déplorez je pense qu'il a été actif sur
rien typiquement mois il se trouve que
donc je réside aux émirats arabes unis
et sur cette région du moyen-orient il
ya eu beaucoup de chance j'ai eu
beaucoup de changement un changement de
paradigme un changement de paradigme
parce que les émirats arabes unis et
bahreïn ont signé ce qu'on appelle les
accords d'abraham
le processus de paix avec les
palestiniens a été mis en avant mais
mais aussi une normalisation
et même plus qu'une normalisation parce
que les émirats arabes unis
contrairement par exemple à l'egypte ou
la jordanie n'ont pas de 2,2
d'historique en termes de conflits donc
il ya un vrai dynamisme je pense qu'elle
moyen-orient c'est une zone de
prospérité c'est dommage que la france
n'ait pas participé à cela et en même
temps les pays du golfe sont très
influent aussi sur une autre de nos
zones d'influencé quand on aura
peut-être pas le temps de parler
malheureusement parce que le temps
presse mais c'est l'afrique on voit que
le golf est simple
vous inquiétez pas justement mais sur le
conflit sur le conflit moi je pense je
pense qu'il ya une position qui est pour
l'instant claire onusienne qui est bien
sûr une solution à deux états que bien
sûr israël a droit à la sécurité
que bien sûr le mans et lorient est en
train de créer une dynamique avec avec
avec notamment comme je le disais les
émirats arabes unis le bahreïn et israël
pour créer c'est justement cette
dynamique économique et donc une
prospérité et moi je la voit d'un très
bon oeil je pense qu'on doit on doit en
douala renforcer on doit l'accompagner
et c'est vraiment dommage que de ce
point de vue là la france alors il nous
reste très peu de temps effectivement
mais mais en afrique on va parler
évidemment de l'intervention sahel
xavier bertrand s'est exprimé sur ce
sujet à écouter
c'est une erreur de réduire les
effectifs français parce qu'il faut que
l'on permette de lutter contre le
terrorisme nous protège et au mali c'est
nous protéger au coin de la rue arts
question mehdi bourny c'est très courant
il nous reste deux minutes est-ce qu'il
faut se retirer du sahel
je pense que la réponse elle est de
prime à bord non il ya eu deux des
communications du gouvernement malien
qui insiste sur la présence française je
pense qu'en plus de ce doc à ce désir il
ya bien sûr un sentiment parfois on
al'impression anti français mais qui
n'émanent pas nécessairement que du
gouvernement doit aussi de certaines
populations de sel parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de problèmes de communication
avec avec la france et certains de ses
représentants et puis surtout il ya un
sujet on a de l'influencé dans secrets
qui n'ont qu'un continent extrêmement
important et si demain on se retire ça
sera mais ça sera nécessairement au
profit d'autres avec qui on peut
travailler mais ça sera nécessairement
au profit unique par exemple de la
russie qui est en train de développer sa
présence à travers wagner la sas était
proche du kremlin et donc nécessairement
d'un point de vue sécuritaire est à plus
d' influence on ne doit pas se retirer
ouais j'ai à me michel notre votre
position sur sur l'afrique et le sahel
notamment est ce que pour lutter contre
le terrorisme
il faut le faire du sahel selon vous
il faut le faire de partout mais il faut
surtout rappeler que l'instabilité au
sahel est due à la guerre désastreuse
encore une fois mené
par sarkozy du coup à la relance des
états unis en libye il est important de
le souligner parce qu'encore une fois
c'est une des marques de lait notre
perdre indépendante de notre perte de
puissance qui a amené justement cette
cette instabilité cette instabilité au
sahel si vous voulez il ya un idéal
l'idéal ce serait que l'armée malienne
elle s'occupe elle-même de ces problèmes
est que nous ayons nos effectifs qui
s'occupe de de nos frontières et de
nauzan de nos intérêts pas comme ça
déverseront dit il faut combattre le
terrorisme au sahel c'est le terrorisme
qu'il ya au au coin de nos grue le
terrorisme de boko haram a priori n'a
pas commis beaucoup d'attentats en
france
écoutez j'ai c'est que la vipère
français c'est constant par contre ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il y a du nez
bulleuses islamistes qui est aujourd'hui
international les islamistes en france
peut s'inspirer d'islamistes ailleurs
qu'il s'agit de dèche de beaucoup
d'autres donc il y a un intérêt à lutter
contre l'islamisme partout où nous
pouvons et où il ya des routes
migratoires vers la france donc ça ce
n'est pas totalement faux mais c'est un
raccourci encore une fois et une
simplification il faut faire preuve de
realpolitik si vous voulez et éviter que
le mali devienne notre afghanistan à
nous et que nous nous en bourbillon
pendant des dizaines d'années à chasser
des personnes qui par ailleurs sont des
nomades qui entourent sont des civils un
autre lot près d'une kalachnikov donc
sur les c'est une c'est une c c'est une
question qui est compliqué qu'il faut
aborder si vous voulez avec réalisme et
sans démagogie
mais encore une fois il y a un idéal à
poursuivre ce qui est la souveraineté
des états y compris de l'état malien est
donc très concrètement là dessus eric
zemmour je pense regrette
que la france doive être obligés
d'intervenir au mali mais il faudra
aller vers une solution
permettre aux manières de reprendre en
main leur leur pays étant simplement
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci
jérémy michel et merci à vous mehdi
bourny ça on aurait pu parler évidemment
de l'algérie non on n'a pas ton c'est un
vaste sujet la politique étrangère merci
en tout cas d'être venu c'est donc
novembre bonne journée la matinale de
france